الا تطورات الميدانيه لحرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا فقد قالت السلطات المحليه في
مدينتيس جنوبي اوكرانيا ان احد عشر شخصا
اصيبوا في قصف ليلي روسي استهدف المدينه
وقالت سلطات مقاطعه
الروسيه قصفت مباني سكنيه في المقاطعه
خلال ساعات الليل ما ادى الاصابه تسعه
اشخاص واض
افتنا خلف اضرارا ماديه كبيره اضافه الى
انقطاع الكهربائي عن اجزاء من المنطقه
المستهدفه
[موسيقى]
ابدا معك مازن وهذه الهجمات على اوديسا
وميكوليف
بالفعل سهام لليوم الثالث على التوالي
الاستهداف الروسي لعدد كبير من المناطق
الاوكرانيه مستمر اوديسا بشكل رئيسي يليها
نيكولايف وصولا الى سومي هذا القصف وفق
القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه تم استخدام به
نحو تسعه عشر صاروخا تم اطلاقها من قبل
القوات الروسيه من ضمنها صواريخ اسكندر
وكاليبر بالاضافه الى مقاله القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه انها تسعه عشره طائره انتحاريه
كانيكاز هاجمت مختلف المناطق في جنوب
البلاد عمليا هذا الاستهداف مستمر لثلاثه
ايام وان كانت حدته هذا المساء اقل وطئه
من اليوم السابق ولكنها كانت استهدافات
كبيره وفق التوصيف العسكري الاوكراني وفق
قياده الاركان التي اشارت الى انها تمكنت
من اسقاط ثمانيه عشر هدفا من اصل تسعه عشر
وتسعه عشر صاروخا اطلقت من اماكن مختلفه
من قبل القوات الروسيه عمليا كان هنالك
ضحايا من المدنيين وفق السلطات المحليه
التي اشارت الى اصابه احد عشر شخصا في
ميكولايف وايضا سقوط عدد من الجرحى في
اوديسا ولكن بطبيعه الحال وفق البيانات
العسكريه الرسميه الاوكرانيه لم تشير الى
اماكن سقوط هذه الصواريخ باستثناء الاشاره
الى منطقتين منطقه سكنيه ومنطقه وصفتها
بمنشات البنيه التحتيه عمليا البيانات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه تكون متحفظه عن ذكر
اي تفاصيل تتعلق باستهداف القواعد
العسكريه الاوكرانيه سواء في اودستا او
غيرها من المناطق في البلاد ولكن ما يمكن
تاكيده بان القصف استمر لليوم الثالث على
التواليب تحديدا في اوديسا وميكوليا على
مستوى خط الجبهه والالتحام بين الطرفين من
خارجه وصولا الى خرسون بينهما البيانات
العسكريه الرسميه الاوكرانيه تشير الى
انها ما زالت تتقدم القوات الاوكرانيه او
تحاول التقدم ضمن ثلاثه محاور محورين في
جابولوجيا ومحور في مقاطعه وتحديدا في باك
حيث تشير الانباء الوارده من القياده
العسكريه الاوكرانيه الى تقدمها شمال
وجنوب باخموت في المقابل كان هنالك معطيات
خلال الايام الماضيه سواء من الناحيه
الاوكرانيه او حتى الروسيه كانت تشير الى
تقدم ضمن محور ليمان وكبيانسك ما بين
مقاطعتي خاركيف
ودونيتس البيان الصادر اليوم عن قياده
الاركان الاوكرانيه يقول بان القوات
الاوكرانيه تمكنت من صدر هذه الهجمات ولكن
بطبيعه الحال ايضا سهام لا يمكن تاكيد هذه
المعطيات من مصادر مستقله نظرا لعدم
امكانيه الوصول الى تلك النقطه من الجبهه
تحديدا حيث يحتدم القتال وهي تجريه هذه
المعارك ضمن مناطق خاليه من السكان ومناطق
حرشيه لا يمكن الوصول اليها بطبيعه الحال
المع متضاربه من الطرفين فيما يتعلق
بالمحور الممتد من كوبيانس وصولا الى
اليمان ولكن البيانات الرسميه الاوكرانيه
تشير الى صد محاولات الهجوم بينما
البيانات الاخرى تشير الى التقدم الروسي
ولكن عمليا ضمن كل هذا الخط خط الجبهه
عمليه الكرو والفرد مستمره واستهداف العمق
عمق الاراضي الاوكرانيه التي تحتلها
القوات الروسيه من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه
وذلك استهداف مستمر لمخازن الذخيره وايضا
لخطط وسكك الحديد والامدادات باتجاه
الخطوط الاماميه وذلك في محاوله لارباك
الخصم من خلال منعه من تجميع قوته
واستجماعه انفاسه والتقاطها في تلك
المناطق ولكن من الواضح ان بعد كل هذه
الفتره منذ مطلع الشهر الماضي مع انطلاق
الهجوم المضاد من الواضح ان هذا الهجوم
يراوح مكانه في اماكن كثيره وباتت الغلبه
الان
للمنازله بالصواريخ والمسيرات ما بين
الطرفين شاهدنا اخر ف صولها في خلال ساعات
الفجر اليوم في اوديسايف